le 23 septembre 2019 à New York aux
Nations Unies
à l'occasion du Sommet mondial pour le
climat
devant les plus grands leaders
politiques et économiques du monde
une jeune fille de 16 ans
pleine d'émotions la voix tremblante et
les larmes aux yeux
interpellait ses femmes et ses hommes
qui ont entre leurs mains l'avenir du
monde en ces termes
comment
osez-vous
vous avez volé mes rêves et mon enfance
il y a des gens qui souffrent il y a des
gens qui meurent
les écosystèmes s'effondrent
et nous sommes à la veille
d'une explosion
et vous
tout ce que vous faites
c'est parler d'argent
et de compte de fait sur une croissance
économique
éternelle
comment
osez-vous
ce jour-là
Greta Thunberg a marqué l'histoire
parce que c'était la première fois
qu'une adolescente
osait avec un pertinence et de manière
aussi franche et directe
interpeller les plus grands puissants du
monde qu'il soit politique économique ou
scientifique sur un sujet qui pourtant
nous concerne tous
ce discours a évidemment fait le tour de
la planète
et
les remarques ont été diverses et
variées
elles allaient
de la haine
au sexisme
au validisme
et elle discréditait et des crédibiliser
cette jeune femme
pourtant ce qu'elle dit est vrai
de multiples rapports scientifiques dont
le GIEC
nous rappelle que la planète va mal
et si ça n'est pas suffisant
il suffit de regarder les catastrophes
naturelles auxquelles nous avons été
confrontés ces dernières années
que ce soit les incendies aux États-Unis
en France ou au Cap Vert
que ce soit les inondations au Pakistan
au Brésil ou en Allemagne
notre planète ne va pas bien
et c'est une gamine de 16 ans
qui est allé rappeler qu'il était temps
de prendre de véritables actions
le discours de Greta Thunberg a
également
éveillé des consciences
sur moi il a agi comme un wake up cool
parce que je me suis toujours considérée
comme une femme engagée
mais parfois vous savez
par paresse par négligence
ou simplement par naïveté
ou par l'acheter
on abandonne certains combats
et bien ce jour-là
Greta Thunberg m'a rappelé ses
engagements
que j'ai toujours eu chevillée au corps
et j'aimerais si vous le voulez bien ce
soir
vous partagez quelques-unes de ces
questions existentielles
qui m'empêche parfois de dormir même si
je ne trouve pas les réponses
nous sommes à une époque extrêmement
complexe et difficile pleine
d'incertitude
et en même temps
c'est une époque
où on a jamais eu autant accès à la
connaissance
c'est une époque
à laquelle tous les développements
scientifiques et technologiques sont
exponentielles
et cela prouve si c'est encore
nécessaire toute l'intelligence et les
potentialités des êtres humains mais
alors pourquoi est-ce que nous n'avons
pas mis
cette intelligence
pour accélérer les droits humains
fondamentaux
pourquoi 75 ans
après la déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme
certaines personnes ont droit de vivre
dans la dignité et avec le respect et
d'autre part
pourquoi
en 2023 les femmes ne sont-elles pas
encore traitées de manière concrète et
pratique comme les égales des hommes
comment est-il possible
qu'une fille n'est pas accès à
l'éducation simplement parce qu'elle est
née fille
comment
peut-on tuer une femme
au prétexte qu'elle portait mal son
voile
comment est-ce qu'il est possible
que certaines personnes imaginent
qu'elles savent mieux que les femmes à
quel moment elles peuvent avoir des
enfants ou pas
comment
comment est-il possible
qu'au 21e siècle
un policier assassine
au vu et au sud de tous
un être humain en lui posant sur la
nuque pendant 8 longues très longues
minutes
son genou
comment est-il possible que 10%
des personnes les plus riches de la
planète
possèdent
75% de la puissance économique mondiale
et comment en même temps
on trouve l'argent pour créer des murs
de barbelés et empêcher les migrants qui
cherchent à fuir la misère et la
pauvreté de venir
au lieu d'utiliser cet argent pour leur
permettre de vivre en dignité chez eux
et d'avoir des perspectives plus
acceptables pour leur avenir
comment est-il possible
que l'on considère qu'une personne
parce que jeune
parce que fille parce que porteuse d'un
autisme
n'a pas le droit de manifester sa colère
sa tristesse et son désespoir
quand à l'état de la planète
dont elle héritera
beaucoup de ces questions n'ont pas de
réponse
pourtant
ce discours de Greta Thunberg m'a
rappelé combien il est important
de rester concentré dessus
lorsque j'étais plus jeune
comme beaucoup d'entre vous certainement
l'une de mes questions préférées c'était
pourquoi
et immédiatement après la réponse
je disais mais c'est pas juste
et que ce soit mon père ma mère ou mes
professeurs me disaient ben oui mais
c'est comme ça et le pire c'est quand il
me disait parce que
bah oui toutes ces personnes là pensent
que le monde est imparfait
et qu'on doit l'accepter en tant que tel
bah oui mais non en fait
on n'est pas obligé d'accepter les
injustices du monde juste parce qu'elles
ont toujours existé
mais je crois
qu'indépendamment de notre genre de
notre couleur de peau de notre religion
que l'on vienne du Nord ou du Sud
qu'on soignait à la ville à la campagne
ou à la montagne
que l'on soit unijambiste que notre
orientation sexuelle soit différente
et bien on devrait avoir la possibilité
d'exprimer nos souffrances
j'ai le sentiment pourtant
que certaines personnes ont abandonné
j'ai le sentiment que certaines
personnes se disent mais à quoi ça sert
tout ça
et bien
je vais vous dire que dans ma vie
j'ai porté de nombreux combats
en tant que femme
en tant que mère
en tant que professionnel
en tant que noir handicapé j'en ai porté
des combats
et il y a quelque chose de magique quand
vous portez certains combats c'est que
vous donnez du sens à votre vie
c'est que vous savez pourquoi vous vous
levez le matin
et même
quand vous parvenez à ne changer la vie
que d'une seule personne
et bien vous vous rendez compte que ces
combats valent la peine
parce que c'est ce qui nous rend humain
les mots de notre époque sont bien trop
nombreux
pour qu'une seule personne une seule
entreprise une seule ONG ou une seule
organisation internationale puisse les
résoudre tous
l'homme providentiel n'existe plus parce
que les paradigmes du leadership ont
fondamentalement changé si tentait que
cet homme providentiel est existé un
jour oui parce que vous avez remarqué
qu'on parle rarement de la femme
providentielle
mais un homme seul ne peut pas
comprendre tous les problèmes du monde
et il peut encore moins avoir toutes les
solutions
donc aucun leader ne peut être
véritablement inclusif
et puis n'oubliez pas que Hitler et
mossolini à leur époque ont été
considérées comme des hommes
providentiels
alors je pense que nous vivons une
époque où l'intelligence collective
est absolument fondamental
elle est critique et elle est
essentielle
parce que chacune et chacun d'entre vous
dans cette pièce
avait un bout du puzzle
vous avez un bout de la solution
mais peut-être
que paresse
par l'acheter
par procrastination
vous avez décidé de ne pas vous en mêler
parce que c'est compliqué
de se battre c'est compliqué d'être un
militant
Greta Thunberg a été traité
de malade mentale
on lui a dit qu'il fallait qu'elle soit
une gentille fille et qu'elle reste à sa
place
pour la décrédibiliser on a dit qu'elle
était
climato hystérique
pourtant cette jeune fille a fait plus
en 5 ans
que des adultes n'ont fait en 20 ans
pour nous alarmer sur l'état de la
planète
alors si vous pensez
que vous êtes trop petit
pour changer le monde
je vous invite à dormir avec un
moustique
et vous réaliserez
que finalement
les personnes qui ont fait les plus
grands changements du monde
les plus grands progrès humain
s les plus grandes avancées
scientifiques ou technologiques
sont nés de personnes qui ont refusé le
statut quo
parce qu'elles avaient une vision
différente du monde
et cette époque en particulier
nous offre l'opportunité
de construire les choses différemment
j'ai porté beaucoup de batailles dans ma
vie
et il y a eu même des périodes où
j'étais totalement désespérée
parce que je n'avais rien
je n'avais pas de réseau je n'avais pas
de contact je n'avais pas d'argent
pourtant j'avais la foi
j'avais la foi en moi
et j'avais la foi dans les autres parce
qu'il y a quelque chose de magique dans
la vie
quand vous avez une vision claire et
précise
et que vous savez
ce que vous voulez atteindre
vous trouvez le chemin et non seulement
vous trouvez les chemins mais vous
trouvez des personnes qui sont prêtes à
vous accompagner sur ce chemin
et je voudrais que vous sachiez
qu'il n'y a rien en ce bas monde qui
soit impossible
quand on a la foi
quand on a la détermination
et quand on a des personnes de qualité
et bienveillantes autour de nous
alors je vous en supplie ne sous-estimez
pas ce pouvoir que vous avez entre les
mains
ne sous-estimez pas votre capacité
chacun à votre place avec les moyens qui
sont les vôtres avec la force ce qui est
la vôtre
ne sous-estimez pas votre capacité à
changer le monde
utilisez ce pouvoir parce que le monde a
besoin de vous
et surtout surtout rêver grand
rêver très grand parce que plus vous
rêver grand
plus vous atteindrez des objectifs
extraordinaires
en l'an 2000
l'époque que tout le monde attendait
avec espoir avec envie et enthousiasme
parce qu'il y avait eu tellement de
progrès sociaux technologiques et
scientifiques qu'on ne pouvait
qu'imaginer des choses extraordinaires à
venir
pour moi ça a été l'une des années les
plus difficiles de ma vie
je venais de divorcer
je n'avais plus rien parce que par
orgueil
par fierté aussi peut-être et sûrement
aussi par des espoirs
j'étais parti sans rien ou plutôt si
j'étais parti avec la chose la plus
importante
la chose avec la personne la plus
importante de ma vie
ma fille
mais j'ai dû tout reconstruire
j'avais une entreprise
je n'avais plus rien
j'ai repris mes études
je suis devenue PDG
de la filiale d'un grand groupe
technologique chinois
et puis après je suis devenue juge
c'était un rêve d'adolescente la justice
et puis quelques temps après
je suis devenue présidente d'un grand
groupe technologique américain pour tout
un continent ça c'était un rêve d'adulte
et puis un soir
je reçois un coup de fil
du premier ministre Jean Castex et
j'apprends que je vais être nommé
ministre de la septième puissance
économique mondiale
et que je vais porter des missions qui
montaient toute ma vie
si on me l'avait dit en l'an 2000
je ne l'aurais pas cru
mais même dans les moments de désespoir
les plus profonds
je n'ai jamais rêvé
petit
j'ai toujours rêver grand
alors je vais vous demander quelque
chose ce soir
rêvé
croyez
ayez foi en vous
et des fois on les autres
et vous verrez rien ne sera impossible
et la première chose à faire
c'est de rêver grand
Albert Camus disait que chaque
génération se croit investir de la
mission de changer de monde
la mienne c'est qu'elle ne changera pas
le monde
mais sa mission est peut-être encore
plus grande
elle consiste à empêcher que le monde ne
se défasse
pour empêcher que notre monde ne se
défasse
nous avons besoin de toutes les volontés
de toutes les intelligences et de toutes
les forces
et nous avons besoin de tous les grands
rêves
et comme le disait Martin Luther King
voler vers vos rêves
si vous ne pouvez pas voler
courez
si vous ne pouvez pas courir marchez
si vous ne pouvez pas marcher
rampez mais quoi qu'il arrive
continuer d'avancer
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]